[Music]
we wanted to create an engine that was
capable of creating truly next
generation of Triple A games but we also
saw that as games were getting bigger so
where the products worked on them and we
wanted to go better not bigger and we
all wanted to be smart and not rely on
brute force
[Music]
the engine should also support how we
work in the studio which is a lot of
quick iterations of a truth I have a lot
of creativity and the freedom to
experiment and prototype
the core of the snowdrop engine is a
node-based scripting system this is
really the beating heart of the engine
that allows us to do what we do
it affects all systems of the engine
from rendering to AI to mission
scripting and the UI it allows us to
quickly develop our assets and to
preview them and interact with them in
ways that have never been done before
the industry it's so easy to use and to
set up that you really have the freedom
and time to explore different options
the editor is basically just a set of
different windows that you can move
around whatever you want and if you work
in a specific way you can adjust the
editor to fit your needs
working with the engine is kind of like
solving a puzzle because the components
are usually already there it's just a
matter of how you combine them together
you can do whatever you want it's
basically it's like Lego because it's
just different building blocks and you
can just does this fit here more less
can make some really cool ways of just
by very simple components I really
enjoyed to work with it
at massive I would call our work style a
form of hectic fun we're very busy all
the time and we like to use our talents
to really try to make the best product
that we can there's always that chance
of somebody's eyes glazing over and they
realizing but what if we do this and if
that person runs out and comes back with
this fantastic idea that somebody hasn't
tried before we're really creating
something new and unique together with
this power and with Eve's ability in the
tools we saw that people really excelled
in what they created
we got amazing graphics we got new
features and we got unique innovations
that we didn't expect but that really
pushed endian forward and all this was
thanks to the foundation that the endian
and the tools applied between the
philosophy of our company and the power
of our technology what we've achieved is
to empower our artists to really achieve
levels of quality never before seen
[Music]